pour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france selon la
procureur de new york l'ancien
conseiller de donald trump pourrait mise
en place un plan visant à escroquer des
centaines des milliers de donateurs une
affaire certainement qui va laisser des
traces
oui bonjour tout d'abord l'acte
d'accusation est assez terrible c'est
tout à fait exact il est très détaillé
et il évoque le fait que à partir de
décembre 2018 style banane et été appelé
pour rejoindre en fait l'idée n'était
pas la sienne mais il est venu comme
associés pour lever défaut défaut privé
et construire à partir de ces faux
certains éléments du fameux mur que le
président trump avait promis à ses
électeurs de construire durant la
campagne de 2016
en fait c'est toute petite distance qui
est concerné mais steve a nommé
quelqu'un qui est très apprécié des
supporter de donald trump et qui est
très connue des milieux conservateurs et
son intervention a permis de lever
immédiatement énormément d'argent
pratiquement 25 millions de dollars il
ambitionnait beaucoup plus mais ils ont
le héros au moins celle sommes là et
steve van s'est présenté comme un
bénévole ainsi que tous ses associés
dans cette affaire et apparemment s'il
faut croire le district sud de new york
d'acte d'accusation et bien une partie
de ces faux a été utilisé pour financer
le train de vie où certains autres
éléments de bananes et certains de ses
proches
donc c'est quelque chose de très sérieux
c'est quelque chose qui d'emblée donne
une très mauvaise image et puis il faut
comprendre une chose c'est que avant le
tribunal guen tribunal médiatique pour
l'instant stib hanon et mis en
accusation lui a plaidé non coupable
mais auprès du grand public
inculpation vos condamnations et c'est
l'image qui restera donc c'est quelque
chose qui n'est pas très bon pour la
propre carrière de ce monsieur je ne
pense pas que ça ait une influence
directe sur tron
parce que trump s'était distancié de
cette entreprise il l'avait toujours
d'ailleurs condamné et lui n'appréciez
pas l'initiative il aurait voulu que
le mur soit construit à partir de fonds
publics puisque c'était une promesse de
sa campagne et un projet présidentiel et
fédérales il ne voulait pas que des
fonds privés viennent se placer là
dedans qu'il n'a jamais été proche de ce
projet il ne connaît pas les associés de
monsieur banane en l'occurrence il a
toujours condamné l'idée est lui même
s'était séparé de monsieur banos n'y a
plus de trois ans puisque steve madden
qui a été son directeur de campagne en
2016 était rentré à la maison blanche
mais comme le disait votre petit résumé
biographique 10ème minute il a quitté au
bout de sept mois
mais c'est quand même on comprend bien
ce que vous dites ans mais fait quand
même difficile de croire que donald
trump n'était absolument pas au courant
de ce qui se veut des dessous de cette
affaire il était au courant mais il
était pas participant donc c'est pas du
tout la même chose s'il était au courant
d'ailleurs parce que l' enquête du
district sud de new york
elle a commencé en octobre dernier et
donald trump est d autant plus au
courant que certains se sont un petit
peu ont été surpris du fait que lorsque
sa campagne a eu un réaménagement de son
état major de campagne à la fin du mois
de juin début juillet il a changé de
directeur et beaucoup de gens
s'attendaient à ce qu'il rappelle steve
banal parce que ce type banane pour les
conservateurs pour les supportes donald
trump
c'est l'auteur le responsable l'auteur
du miracle de 2016
personne ne s'attendait à ce que tron
gagne et tout le monde estime que s'il a
gagné c'est grâce à la stratégie
extrêmement précises de style vannoote
donc beaucoup de gens s'attendaient à ce
que ce type banane reviennent pour la
réélection du président est à l'évidence
il n'est pas revenu
c'est parce que il avait cette affaire
qui à l'époque n'était pas public mais
dont le président avait connaissance si
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que le
président lui-même avait envoyé un tweet
au printemps j'ai pas la date exacte
mais lorsque certaines personnes ont
évoqué l' enquête
il s'en est il a pris ses distances
immédiatement en disant qu'il avait
toujours condamné qui n'avait jamais
soutenu ces personnages qu'il n'avait
jamais soutenu l'idée lui même estimait
que cette enquête
le faisait paraître comme inactifs
inefficace et quel est l'état de leurs
relations
aujourd'hui ils sont ils sont brouillées
en fait ils sont brouillées ça c'est
jamais bien passé à la maison blanche
donald trump estiment que steve madden
jouer jouer perso c'est à dire qu'il
n'essaie fuite est un certain nombre
d'informations pour son propre bénéfice
qu'ils entretenaient une certaine forme
de chaos et c'est vrai c'est un petit
peu sa façon de travailler et donc les
deux hommes ne se sont jamais entendus
lorsqu'il s'est agi de travailler
ensemble à la maison blanche
par contre du point de vue des idées du
point de vue de la stratégie ça se
passait très bien et steve madden
lui-même ne s'est jamais ne s'est jamais
retourné contre donald trump s'est au
contraire quelqu'un qui l'a toujours
soutenu mais qui manifestement a eu des
ambitions qui sont allés au delà donald
trump
il a cherché à fond à monter une sorte
d'internationale nationaliste populiste
il est venu en europe il a soutenu
marine le pen c'est un grand allié de
nigel farrage qui est la personne
derrière la stratégie du break sites au
royaume uni il a soutenu un certain
nombre de mouvements populistes en
europe donc il a eu des ambitions qui a
mais au delà des états unis et en ce qui
concerne travaillait avec trop mais ça
ne s'est pas forcément bien passé merci
à vous gérald olivier je rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur alips spécialiste
des états unis siens